E aí
[Música]
o Olá Quando foi que você nasceu digo
qual foi a última vez que você nasceu
sim a gestação nos faz maravilhar com as
possibilidades da nossa chegada aqui
este mundo as possibilidades do nascer
do nascer e quanto aqui existirmos
Convido você me acompanhar nessa viagem
na percepção inicial do parto o fardo
que momento fabuloso vida nova como
cheios de ar melhorou nos prontos para
registrar tantas novas experiências o
recém-nascido e seus opostos de um lado
a delicadeza a fragilidade a
vulnerabilidade é o mesmo tempo um
potencial oculto de uma força
imensurável propulsora da vida e de suas
possibilidades
e já na vida intrauterino tudo é tão
mágico Olha só uma placenta que não
existia surge desenvolve com mais teria
as suas funções ela pinta do corpo
materno tudo que é necessário para
desenvolvimento de um embrião de um feto
e desenvolve devolve para esse mesmo
corpo materno aquilo que é tóxico ao
feto e logo depois do parto como um
botão mágico aquele que estava em
perfeita Harmonia conexão com outros
simplesmente tá liberado e é eliminado
quanto ao feto um corpo estranho ou
tamanho que o Gerson veja só sim metade
da genética do pai metade da genética da
mãe um ser geneticamente diferente que
por isso devia ser expulso rejeitado mas
muito antes pelo contrário é acolhido
nutrido protegido no santuário uterino
o e fabuloso é isso o poder da vida bom
eu sou a Soraia joislane ginecologista
obstetra e fala o que tem o privilégio
de trabalhar na minha opinião com a obra
mais perfeita da criação de Deus ninguém
nunca discordou aliás no evento respeito
de médicos e que eu vou desse jeito logo
a seguir um colega urologista Levantou
se apresentou dizendo trabalho com a
segunda obra mais perfeita de Deus o
homem porque a primeira é a mulher amo o
que faço e faço o que amo mas nem sempre
foi assim um acidente de percurso peço
permissão para contar uma parte um
pouquinho da minha história quando eu
estava lá com os meus 14 anos no ensino
fundamental um coleguinha me perguntou o
que que eu ia ser eu respondi médica e
nós dois nos assustamos com uma risada
uma risada irônica da professora que
estava do lado não não foi
é que nem eu guardei eu me lembro
perfeitamente não guardei nenhuma mágoa
daquilo eu entendia perfeitamente Afinal
eu estudava na escola pública de
Periferia na minha região existe uma
faculdade para medicina que era
particular e a minha mãe trabalhava
naquela escola servindo cafezinhos e
lavando o banheiro mas eu nem queria
saber só sabia que eu queria fazer
medicina então procurei a saber
descobrir com o próximo passo era me
matricular no científico que era
preparatório para ao que chamava
vestibular
é bom algumas pessoas procurar meus pais
e diz aconselhar a deixaram fazer
científico que é filho de pobre devia
fazer curso profissionalizante as meus
pais me apoiaram Então fui lá fiz o meu
científica e no final foi lá prestar o
meu sonhado o vestibular para medicina
Oi e aí um choque de realidade estava
muito distante o que era cobrado daquilo
que eu sabia parecia de fato que
medicina era algo assim muito distante
eu te vi professores maravilhosos
Mestres a quem teve toda a minha
gratidão todo meu carinho pessoas que
amavam que faziam que ensinaram que
deviam que alimentava o sonho dos seus
alunos mas depois mente eu tive pessoas
que não amavam que faziam que não
ensinava o que deviam que trabalhava por
salários e que talvez não tem a noção do
prejuízo na vida das pessoas que
passaram por eles
Oi e aí fiz o meu vestibular não passei
meus pais acreditando no meu sonho foi
lá no ano seguinte e me matriculou num
cursinho preparatório para o vestibular
e aí pagou os 6 meses de cursinho em 12
parcelas meu pai era auxiliar de
pedreiro e aqui uma pausa como é bom ter
paz ter pessoas família ao seu lado que
acredita no seu sonho que acredita no
seu potencial e que apesar das
dificuldades da distância sabe que dão
apoio naquilo que pode bom no final do
ano acabaram as reservas do meu pai eu
não passei mas eu prestei uma prova para
um concurso público e me tornei efetivo
agora eu era efetiva no estado no cargo
de auxiliar de secretaria de escola
estadual e aí e aí eu podia financiar o
meu cursinho então comecei a seguir
aquela frase
o Inácio de Loyola que diz assim
passa-se a roupa de acordo com pano que
se dispõe trabalhava de dia boa noite
não deu certo mais um ano tudo bem fui
lá tem que mudar de estratégia conversei
na minha escola vai lá de de noite fazer
cursinho de dia chegava em casa à noite
tornava estudar mais um pouquinho mais
uma tentativa mais um ano e de novo sem
sucesso o choro meu e de minha mãe mais
uma vez nós estava eu no quinto ano para
quinta tentativa e aí já Surgiu uma
novidade aquela faculdade na região que
era particular se tornou Universidade
Estadual o sonho parecia mais próximo e
na faculdade desculpa no cursinho eu já
era veterana inclusive os professores já
diziam que naquele ano e não existiam
mais 20 vagas para medicina existiam 19
por quê Porque uma era minha então tinha
tudo para ser aquele ano e lá vou eu
prestar o vestibular é
e acreditem não passei aquela noite que
eu também escutei o choro do meu pai
e no ano seguinte estava lá eu de novo
no início do ano determinada começando
do básico reconhecer na humildade que
tinha que começar do início como sempre
E aí surgiu uma proposta não cursinho
prestar o sushi um bolsão que se
passasse por 12 meses eu não precisaria
preocupar com mensalidade bom já era um
caminho precisava dedicar mais a
concorrência era alta acho uma distância
aí para minha casa e o cursinho de mais
ou menos uma hora caminhando
bom então eu peguei o meu décimo
terceiro salário como funcionária
pública comprei uma bicicleta e pronto
resolvido pedir exoneração do meu cargo
público estadual
em algumas pessoas acharam que eu tava
ficando maluca como era possível trocar
o certo pelo duvidoso
e aliás filho de pobre ser efetiva no
estado já era um sonho de fato ser
auxiliar de secretaria era algo de muito
honradez era um serviço importante mas
não era o que eu amava a fazer então foi
a mais um ano dentro de casa mana
feriado todos os dias mas estudar para
mim nunca foi um sacrifício eu sempre
fiz isso com gostou sempre acredita no
potencial e o conhecimento traz a
transformação e cada vez ficava mais
próximo E aí depois de um ano de
tentativa lá pela certa vez
e finalmente escutamos o meu nome se
anunciado no rádio eu estava entre as
inscritas em paz aprovadas para o curso
de medicina na Universidade Estadual de
Montes Claros meu Deus que momento
esperado na faculdade eu descobri minha
paixão pela ginecologia e Obstetrícia
tornei-me especialista em saúde da
mulher e não Obstetrícia e gestação de
alto risco hoje eu tenho meu consultório
do jeito que eu imaginei meu cantinho
que eu amo trabalho no hospital de
referência alta complexidade da minha
cidade e nele Sou professora dos
Acadêmicos da faculdade na qual me
formei a quem o tempo tanta gratidão a
unimontes e que turma espetacular aquela
verdadeiras amizades que trago comigo
como tesouros
e dizem que uma semente morre para dar
origem uma árvore nela vários frutos
muitos outros frutos que eu colhi foi
aprovação desse tempo todo dedicação foi
aprovação em vários concursos que pude
escolher um desses era uma vaga Vale
vaga única para médica na região para
uma região na Polícia Militar de Minas
Gerais prestei o concurso fui aprovada
vaga minha hoje também estou no posto de
Capitão ou capitã oficial médica do
quadro de oficiais da Saúde da Polícia
Militar de Minas Gerais lugar que
trabalham com orgulho com alegria lugar
em que as pessoas a não o que faz e isso
muito me inspira amar o que faz tudo
nisso faz sentido para mim quando estou
trabalhando eu não tenho fumo e não vejo
o tempo passar eu trabalho com Belo ele
é Essência o amor vejo só às vezes um
paciente me liga no início de uma
gestação chorando por que sangrou um
pouquinho ou
e outras de abrir mais adiantadas estão
lá preocupadas me ligando Doutora o meu
bebê mexer um pouco menos isso é normal
e o logo penso que bonito é isso Que
lindo nem nasceu nem vi o rostinho e já
ama tanto trabalho para mim é o conceito
que houve certa vezes e que preenche
perfeitamente é o que eu faria se eu
tivesse de férias
E desde a minha adolescência Eu
participo de retiros inaciano você tira
de silêncios espirituais e aprendi com
Santo Inácio de Loyola um dos seus
legados
e olha só ele diz assim não é um muito
saber que sacia e satisfaz a alma mas o
sentir e saborear internamente as coisas
aliás sabor ele tem a mesma origem no
seu radical sabedoria Sapiência
sagacidade do latim sapere ter custo ter
sabor para mim saborear a vida no que
faz é uma forma de deixar um legado
Lógico que nem sempre na vida
profissional é tudo extasia momentos
difíceis a passo os preços decisões
rápidas Vidas Em Questão ou casais de
alto risco de gestação de alto risco de
altíssimo risco Que acompanho quantas
prestações quantas perdas anteriores
quantos desejam que aquela gestação
chega ao final é o investimento
emocional o alto e que mesmo a gente
aplicando todos
Os mais modernos da Medicina e
aprendendo a viver com eles um dia de
cada vez sim na ginecologia tantas
coisas com mulheres que passa na minha
vida deixa um pouquinho de perfume dela
nas minhas vidas na minha vida
permitindo viver uma vida melhor
esse é o caminho se faz caminhando e que
delícia quando conseguimos colocar nele
a paz e alegria interiores a luz e o
amor divino a doçura a simplicidade a
humildade a caridade ou escutar a
generosidade EA compaixão também são
Pilares importantes na caminhada eu
tenho percebido que o nascer é continuar
e que delícia que milagre é esse
enquanto eu morrer eu posso desculpa
enquanto eu posso morrer sim eu posso
morrer para aquilo que me aprisiona para
aquele que me maltrata que me traz a
ansiedade que me perturba que não me
deixa viver uma vida plena e eu posso
nascer para o novo para novas
experiências como criança com os olhares
cheios de entusiasmo e de paixão pela
vida
o vento experimentando degustado em
perfeita comunhão com o universo com a
criação Renata Teixeira em uma de suas
canções raízes nos fala esta Maravilha
amanhecer é uma lição do universo que
nos ensina que é preciso Renascer o novo
amanhece
é o novo amanhece
e escutando certas vezes uma entrevista
do escritor Ariano Suassuna a um
Jornalista ele disse assim olha o
cachorro come osso porque não lidam
picanha não
nós estamos em pandemia e é visível medo
das pessoas de morrer não é aliás não é
só para anemia em aqui não tem medo de
morrer
a morrer perder a vida que vida
Em que parte da nossa vida de fato
Estamos nos permitindo delícias ou nos
acostumamos com tá osso tá duro sem
sabor mais vai
nós estamos com medo de perder a vida ou
de Partir sem ter nos permite ver aquilo
que realmente queríamos
e a um livro conhecido universalmente a
Bíblia e nele há um momento para mim
maravilhoso encontro de Jesus com um
cego o cérebro procura Jesus e os Jesus
pergunta para você o que você é o que
você quer
E eu achava essa pergunta tão sem
sentido perguntar para um cego que ele
quer mas depois eu pude ver a beleza por
trás dessa pergunta que pergunta linda
é uma do Tesouro Zé
me deu oportunidade alguém a falar eu
quero a oportunidade que nós temos
enquanto vivermos de dizer eu quero
Então segue eu quero enxergar enxergou
Quando eu olho lá para mim adolescência
um coleguinha me perguntou Soraia o que
que você quer eu respondi
a fazer medicina ser médica
e quando eu olho para trás Parecia tudo
tão quase impossível tão distante uma
vitória nem médica depois na residência
eu descobri que eu queria fazer
ginecologia e Obstetrícia mas eu queria
fazer naquele mesmo lugar que as
professoras que me inspiraram fizeram E
aí outra dificuldade eu era do interior
era capital outro concurso novas provas
eu te uma criança de três anos mas aí
veio de novo e eu quero o desejo a
dedicação acreditar E aí eu passei em
três hospitais escolas de referência e
por escolher aquele e que as minhas
professoras se especializaram e quando
eu olho para trás tudo passou tão rápido
como tudo valeu a pena uma aquele seis
anos que eu fiquei prestando cursinho
parece que foram mesas incrível isso não
é
e hoje quando eu vou dormir eu tô
querendo cada vez mais um hábito de ao
deitaram antes de adormecer pensar como
foi o meu dia hoje hum que delícia um
dia delicioso se eu partir dormindo
partirei em paz
o Nelson Mandela tem uma poesia que para
mim ela é fabulosa ela nos fala do nosso
dos nossos medos e Engraçado que ele
coloca lá sabe qual que é o nosso maior
terror o nosso maior medo nós não temos
medo dos nossos desajustes das nossas
não adequações que o nosso maior medo
não são Trevas o maior medo é da nossa
looks que nós temos consciência de como
nós somos poderosos nós temos medo do
nosso poder E aí ele pergunta lá a
poesia Quem Sou Eu para ser para tosa
para ser maravilhosa que sou eu para ser
brilhante para ser Fabulosa Aí depois
ele pergunta mas quem sou eu para não
ser
Oi e aí de forma linda ele coloca Você é
filho do universo faça sua parte luz
brilhe
Hoje nós estamos aqui agora porque nós
acreditamos no Poder do Agora
e eu agora Pet deixa a sua luz brilhar
diante dos homens deixa a sua luz
brilhar diante do mundo sabe em nós ao
Divino em você a centelha do divino
então não tenha medo deixe a sua luz
brilhar
Oi Ester Giovana Maria Isabel Maria
Fernanda Gil diz
bom então só uma pergunta para vocês
e o que você quer
e por favor não me responda rápido essa
pergunta é muito preciosa o que você
quer
é muito obrigada